well pretty good weather to rally for
our Aces that's right and Rocky stopped
by the Raider at the studio just before
they head out to the Celebration to see
a new way they're bringing cheer to the
community
so the raiderets are bringing more cheer
to the community by opening up their
official Studio to the public so you are
invited to come dance with football's
fabulous females Marina how closely will
the public be dancing with these ladies
well just about as close as we are right
now we have Audrey Mel Alexis and Lila
teaching our dance and fitness classes
much fun speaking of dance and fitness
are our Aces you know our stars of the
day they love both of those things if
you could pick an Asus player to join
the Raider at Squad who would it be well
that's not a question who is it ladies
Asia oh Asia we love Adrian Wilson and
now why is that she came to our
auditions in April to wish us good luck
and uh she's officially a part of the
squad she's captain of line five oh snap
okay Asia now here's an idea why don't
we have the aces since they're you know
playing in the office or they're in the
off season now come join the squad on
the field one day absolutely you heard
it here first let's make that happen all
right I know you guys have to warm up
and get ready for the parade today so do
your thing redress
now what will the studio bring to the
community to the studio will bring
mentorship and we're just here to help
support the community and guide kids and
adults of all ages into their path
towards success and dance I love that
it's perfect and how can people enroll
in classes Maria they can find us at
raideretsostudio.com easy as that well
go Aces and always go Raiders we'll send
it back to you